[Music]
what's up everyone
how you been finding the current anime
season so far you know i just can't
spend a week without seeing reactions
about it on my newsfeed
attack on titan is in its peak form now
and with new seasons of promise
neverland and re zero
how could the hype not be there don't
forget other blockbusters like horimia
and
redo of gila as i very accurately
predicted ended up being the
inter-species reviewers of the season in
terms of real-world drama not to the
extent the latter got but
it's there speaking of memes and other
hilarities have you seen
x arm people have been calling it a
money laundering scheme and i find that
absolutely hilarious
enough of the current season though for
today we're going to be focusing on 10
of the most anticipated titles this
spring
2021 because as soon as this blockbuster
of a season ends it feels good to know
that we'll have more great anime coming
up
any predictions of what most people
would be excited for leave a comment
with your pick
and hit that subscribe button
we start off the list with eden zero
carrying on some creator goodwill
eden zero has undeniably become one of
the most anticipated series this coming
season there's been quite a lot of buzz
about eden zero in my communities and i
don't find that surprising who doesn't
want some light-hearted fun with space
and technology
shiki rebecca and happy are here to keep
you company and they'll keep you
entertained all throughout this
adventure where we meet new friends and
allies along the way
it's an exciting adventure through the
cosmos and i'm looking forward to it on
a related note
the thing just screams hiro mashima
whether it's the quirky art the recycled
designs the light-hearted plot or the
emphasis on fan service you'll pretty
much get what you expect from the
creator
if you found yourself enjoying fairy
tale or rave master you should
definitely give this one a shot
[Music]
next we take a look at zombieland saga
revenge
one of the big surprises i had around
three years ago was zombieland saga i
first heard about it through a collab
with shadowverse and i didn't know what
to expect especially with a title like
that and the art
imagine my surprise though when it
turned out to be an idol show an absurd
and over-the-top take on the idol genre
in fact
i personally found the first zombieland
saga to have ended in a pretty
satisfying note it had a lot of good
moments
and in the time that it was airing it
had quite a lot of clout and had memes
spreading in the community it ended up
being an anime that got people wanting
more the announcement of a sequel didn't
completely surprise me and i'll join the
rest of the zombieland saga fans in
anticipating this sequel
what could be in store for us in this
second season of zombieland saga
mappa will be bringing us the series
this spring so stay tuned for it
[Music]
here's a school anime featuring
teenagers coming right your way
hayase nagatoro delight in one thing
bullying her senpai she makes his life a
complete hell at school and makes him do
whatever interests her at the time
however in a twist of fate her senpai
doesn't hate it in fact he still finds
himself getting roped into her antics
all the time
as the time goes on perhaps some
unexpected developments in a case of
romance could develop from all of this
think something along the lines of
takagi-san but far
far less innocent from what i've read of
the manga and the current reception to
it i think that this series could end up
quite controversial still i think it's a
rom-com that's worth talking about
and i know a lot of people are excited
to see how it will turn out
now here's another surprise usually
seasonal isekai and the sea of them that
aren't really projected to blow up
rarely get 24 episodes let alone a
second season
but by some act of fate how not to
summon a demon lord got it and it will
premiere this spring
2021. it's an announcement that came
rather out of nowhere but needless to
say
fans of the show were thrilled people
mostly recognize the series for the fan
service
and having some knowledge of the coming
arcs i know you'll be up for more of the
same
diablo rem and shura will be back for
more misadventures as our hero continues
the journey
to find his meaning as the demon king of
his new world get ready to see diablo
unleash his coolest spell this season
too comedic hijinks unfortunate
implications
and more awesome puny magic awaiting
this coming spring let's see how the new
studio fares in taking the reigns of
adapting this series catch me
if you can mr holmes
next in line is the second season of
moriarty the patriot
i've been singing the praises about
moriarty the patriot a lot that's not a
secret
i just like how the show tackled a lot
of psychological and moral dynamics
moriarty has been quite the legendary
antagonist in traditional literature and
it feels enlightening to see him go to
work in fixing the messed up systems of
the world through his villainous ways we
should expect to see some more of the
same engaging arcs that made the first
season so immersive there's a big reason
why moriarty the patriot has been
gaining quite a bit of steam these days
and a lot of that has to do with the
excellent writing
when i think that the show's pretty good
it's not exactly popular
even during the run of its first season
i think that it's just about right the
moriarty patriot's second season finds
itself near the bottom half of the list
at number five we take a look at megalo
box 2.
how long has it been since i heard the
name megalo box people often call ippo
the signature boxing anime but i think
the megalo box has also had a pretty
good run a couple of years ago megalo
box turned out to be a niche favorite
among people who enjoyed how it combined
sports
sci-fi and drama in one powerful package
and i can see that the same people are
looking forward to the second season
this spring the first season of megalo
box was a gritty emotional ride
that showcased the excitement of
fighting the hardships the grind
and the brave journey of an individual
who takes part in what i can describe as
an extreme boxing tournament was a very
enjoyable ride to be in and i'm
definitely looking forward to what else
megalo box has in store for us
joe will be punching his way back to our
screens this april so be there for it
how about a remake for our fourth place
series shaman king fights its way to the
fourth spot on our list
it's been a long time coming but we're
finally getting a much-awaited remake
for one of the most popular shonen
series in the early 2000s
shaman king's first adaptation was a
memorable one that defined a lot of our
childhoods but looking back at it as an
adult i think that it's a bit lacking in
some parts but fret not everyone we're
finally getting an adaptation that will
faithfully adapt the manga this coming
season
shaman king is back with a vengeance
from what we've seen in the trailers i
think that this is a remake that we
won't be disappointed in i'm so excited
to see the shaman fight remastered with
modern technology that doesn't mean that
the only longtime fans are welcome here
if you're up for some supernatural
action with a lot of elements similar to
bleach or the like feel free to hop in
and start your journey with yo asakura
this 2021
our third most anticipated anime for
spring 2021 is
tokyo revengers how about a high octane
action thriller for this upcoming season
tokyo revengers comes to our screen this
coming season and it promises a lot of
suspenseful action
and time travel shenanigans basically
it's about our protagonist hanagaki
finding out that his girlfriend was
murdered by a gang of vicious criminals
vengeance against a powerful group like
that would be next to impossible
normally fortunately hanagaki finds
himself the recipient of the most
powerful plot starter in anime
the ability to travel back in time now
finding himself another chance hanagaki
looks to infiltrate the gang and save
his girl before it's too late
bad boys violent action and bonds forged
by fire those are things you can expect
from a show like this
tokyo revenges is a show that will go
full throttle and won't let
up
[Music]
in second places to your eternity this
one surprised me a little bit to be
honest it's not every day that you get
an artistic and intricate anime like
this as one of the headliners of the
season but for spring 2021 it definitely
feels like the second most anticipated
show as far as my circle is concerned on
second thoughts
how could it be from the trailers alone
this thing just looks gorgeous
plus it's from the woman who gave us a
silent voice so there has to be some
hype around it the story is basically
about an alien object that can take the
form of other things
it adapts to its environment and starts
learning about the world until it hits
the jackpot
and takes the form of a human with its
new form it sets off on an adventure of
discovery to find humanity's purpose and
concept of identity i've read the manga
a bit and from what interesting things i
saw from it i'd say that this show is
definitely deserving of its spot to be
second most anticipated anime of spring
2021
we finished with our most anticipated
anime this upcoming season
what else did you expect but my hero
academia
four seasons two movies a manga that's
very strong
i mean if it wasn't for demon slayer i'm
pretty sure at this point
my hero academia has the crown of most
popular and hyped ongoing shonen title
all to itself already the fifth season
for my hero academia continues our story
with a spectacular training arc for
manga readers who have eagerly awaited
an anime adaptation of the joint
training arc
it's finally here we finally get to see
classes 1a
and 1b take on each other in yet another
amazing tournament arc
also if we get far enough in this season
we could also reach the league of
villains arc where our favorite group of
antagonists gets the spotlight in their
own arc my hero academia continues to go
on a role as we head towards spring 2021
i don't know about you but i've not been
this excited for my hero academia season
ever since the one with all might
versus all for one season 5 starts on
the 27th of march 2021
are you ready to go plus ultra once more
i sure am
let's go i'm extremely excited for
spring 2021 and
so should you be there are so many great
shows to look forward to that i think i
missed out on some of them when making
this list and all that while we're in
the middle of a blockbuster season
ourselves what about you
what would you put as your top 10
anticipated titles this spring 2021
share your thoughts down in the comments
section and maybe you could compare your
list to your fellow fans while you're at
it before you leave
don't forget to drop a like hit that
subscribe button and come back for more
i've got a lot more videos prepared for
you so i'll be seeing you next time
[Music]
you